I did retesting a few months ago and started some new supplements for anxiety and depression.
It really hasn't.
I really haven't noticed a huge difference.
I am on a lot of supplements, and it's very costly, so I just want to be on supplements
and focus on the cancer.
What would be your recommendations?
Well, if I put you on adaptogens and things specifically for the anxiety and depression
and they're not working, then biomeans don't spend the money and buy them again.
Now understand, when you're on a supplement, like an adaptogen core, that it could take
a while for it to kick in.
But if you've been on it a couple of months, and it's really not helping, then biomeans
maybe just phase off of that.
Look on the parasympathetic nervous system, look up parasympathetic nervous system stimulation
on the member site, and it's on the stop-fighted cancer course, and it's on our website.
You want to stimulate the parasympathetics to help calm the anxiety.
Also on the blog posts, and on the member site, you'll see a vagal creatiolerve tab is
the vagus nerve, also called vagal nerve stimulation.
So you want to stimulate creatiolerve tab.
That is your main parasympathetic nervous system stimulation.
So you want to work on that, but then just get back and use just your cancer supplements and
stay on those.